before a devastating fire ripped through
this detention center in yemen's capital
last week
the ethiopians being held there
confronted their guards to demand better
living conditions
that's when survivors say who the
security forces locked them in a hangar
and told them to say their final prayers
before firing something at them
he fired the projectile at us through
the hole and the fire caught onto the
piles of pillars we were sleeping on
the room filled up with smoke and we
also had to scream as we cried for help
some of us started to faint and fall to
the ground
i saw my friends banging to death i
didn't receive any help after that
nightmare
dozens of people were killed in the
blaze after a tour through a hangar with
350
people inside mostly migrants from the
horn of africa
the united nations is calling for an
independent investigation into the cause
of the fire
tens of thousands of migrants pass
through yemen each year attempting to
reach
wealthy gulf countries in order to
provide for their families back home
they're exposed to kidnapping torture
and abuse while navigating
a deadly conflict survivors of the fire
accused the houthis of using them to
feed the war effort
when we told them we were going on a
hunger strike they said they'd force
fetus and send us to fight on the front
we said we would not fight because this
isn't our country we're refugees
our country is facing a bigger war than
the one here we couldn't live in our own
country so we escaped here
the international organization for
migration has demanded the release of
thousands of migrants being held at
houthi run facilities
these young people are faced and sold
out
unrealistic versions of of the journey
by smugglers and
traffickers and they are not telling
them the truth of
the true real and difficulties of the of
of
that journey one group at least was
given a way out
150 ethiopians were evacuated on tuesday
on the first repatriation flight since
the pandemic began
andrew chappelle al jazeera